they came to this FIFA World Cup
qualifier in their thousands to raise
awareness fans dressed in the
traditional black and white Czech cfia
carrying the Palestinian flag were there
to show support for the players but also
to protest against Israel's war on Gaza
I'm going to be supporting Palestine
because we think that this game is a
venue for us to protest against the
genocide that's happening now in Gaza
and the occupation we were given these
toys at the gate from uh two guys and
they asked us to throw them um to the
court at 710 in support of the children
that have been killed in Palestine I'm
Kuwai and we should come here because
this is a humanitarian issue and a lot
of people have been dying so we're
coming here to support to our
brothers it was a match full of symbolic
gestures the Palestinian team wore their
cfas during the national anthems and
both teams observed a minute of silence
for those killed in the war the
Australian players have also shown their
support by pledging a portion of their
match fees towards humanitarian efforts
in
[Music]
Gaza the opening goal it was Australia
who went ahead early Harry Su heading
the ball in from a corner extraordinary
short Alat but just before the break M
batat nearly equalized for Palestine
forcing Australian keeper Matty Ryan
into
action
Australia ultimately came away with the
one-nil victory but the Palestinian team
delivered their message loud and
clear of course today we played for our
people in Palestine um that was the
cause for our uh game today uh we just
think that when we play these type of
matches this type of big matches this
the first thing that we think about
especially with what's happening right
now this situation over there um and we
say sorry to all our fans in Alis sorry
we couldn't win the main m message is re
exist we are here we're living human
beings who exist and we have the freedom
to play and to enjoy the game of
football many people don't know that
palestin is here we are here the
Palestinian team may have lost this
match but they're showing tenacity and
resilience playing against a back job
before perhaps most importantly for
their fans they rais the voice of
Palestinians on a world stage Joan
garosa Al jazer Q8
City make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer